and with all due respect to Ben Affleck
we recently lost the definitive Batman
yeah Kevin Conley yeah and I was just
wondering if you had any personal
anecdotes or stories you'd like to share
I would love to thank you for [ __ ]
affording me the moment
um
uh you know I first watched the Batman
animated series like everybody else well
everybody else who was alive when it was
on
um when it first started airing on Fox
they did it as a prime time show first
and then it moved to the afternoons
um and you know as a comic book loving
kid as we all know that is one of the
absolute Still Remains one of the
absolute best representations of Batman
and Gotham in any media across all forms
and
that voice
the voice of Batman as portrayed by
Kevin Conroy and of course Bruce Wayne
he does Bruce Wayne as well became the
voice very quickly within a year became
the voice that I heard whenever I read a
comic book because he became the
definitive Batman so I know him first as
a fan of the man's work and then thanks
to the [ __ ] that I do for a living I
wind up gravitating toward or circling
people I admire you know we kind of work
in the same field and stuff and I'm very
Fanboy oriented so people find out I
like a thing and stuff and we wind up in
the same circles so I'd known Kevin for
a few years I met him at cons and stuff
like that very briefly always
deferential to him
um I knew he was a big theater kid
Broadway guy and I knew I wanted to get
him when I started Fat Man on Batman the
podcast I wanted to get him to come on
we went to New York to record them at
the studios where they do the moth I had
to rent a place and stuff rather than
make them go down to Jersey or drag them
out to California and I met him he's a
tall [ __ ] wonderful guy doesn't you
know you've seen what he looks like but
I remember the first time I saw it I was
like that's Batman like that voice comes
out of that guy and [ __ ] milky [ __ ]
voice of
steady stability voice of justice and
comfort you know because he could easily
dial it up to be like I'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of you for stealing that purse
or you know I've got you it's okay the
voice of comfort and the worst moment of
all time of your life so he came in and
we did a whole show and he's absolutely
wonderful I think we're putting it up
this week because it all went beyond a
paywall years ago but we're gonna put
that episode up for everybody here but
in the episode
um like I was going through some [ __ ]
with red State and a bunch of people
were like you're a [ __ ] idiot blah
blah blah so I asked him very
pathetically I was like can you
can you tell me that I'm doing okay
as Batman like I remember that yeah I
listened to it and he [ __ ] took it so
seriously they put on the Batman voice
and was literally said everything I've
needed to hear particularly at that
moment in time so you know it was fun
for the bit people on the podcast loved
it but what people didn't know is I
clipped that off and it was on my next
three phones and whenever I was like at
my lowest I would [ __ ] dig it up and
Batman would be like you're doing the
right thing Kevin
and I was like yes
it was a magic uh Magic [ __ ] man he
came in and played uh if you've ever
seen yoga hosers he came in and did a
quick scene I put it up you could skip
the movie you can see it in the one
tweet I put up the other day
um but he came and and played and he was
just so lovely everybody you know I
introduced him I was like is one of the
[ __ ] he's done many things but he'll
forever be known as this guy and
everyone want nuts and [ __ ] and he was
just like I am the Knight it was really
really sweet
um I was just having a text conversation
with him like two weeks [ __ ]
I was just having a sex conversation
with him two weeks ago about coming this
mod Castle I had sent him an email uh
because I thought I had his number but
it was a different Kevin Gomery and so I
sent him an email instead and I never
check email and uh said hey man I'm
doing a bunch of things I want you to
come this mod castle and we're gonna
watch like the [ __ ] episodes of
Batman that made me cry and we're gonna
talk about them and one of them is like
the Justice League episode where you
know Ace of the Royal Flush Gang dies
that always circulates on Twitter it's
[ __ ] insanely moving so I was like
we're gonna pick the [ __ ] ones that
Mega's crime we're gonna sit down and
[ __ ] do it retrospective and I didn't
hear from him and then he texted me out
of the blue and he was like uh did you
get my emails and I hadn't because I
never checked email and he's like I've
been a little under the weather but I
would love to come to the theater and do
that let's aim for the beginning of 2023
and I was like okay Batman and then I'm
[ __ ]
uh the people I work with at Masters of
the Universe because he was a merman for
us that texted me early the other
morning and they were just like Kevin's
gone
[ __ ] rant my emails to read what he
had written
foreign
Stock's losing anybody that's
exceptional at their job right let's
let's just start there the man was
exceptional at what he did
sucks when you lose the ones that are
like beautiful human beings that guy was
such a good guy man really good guy
um so yeah I'll miss him forever I was
lucky to have known him at all and more
importantly I was lucky to have had him
as my Batman in my lifetime I'll hear
his voice from now until the end of time
he did his job so [ __ ] good that even
when Kevin's gone he'll always be in my
head whenever I read [ __ ] Batman
thanks for letting me bring him back
here thank you and thank you for your
award
[Applause]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask if anything every
Saga has a 10-year anniversary ladies
and gentlemen and this is what happens
with Jay and Silent Bob get old off
Kevin Smith
[Music]